how could you convince tony to bring the  kill tony crew to maryland well once  maryland gets a  major metropolis then i think it'll be  easy to convince him  as long as your  biggest city is bought baltimore it's  going to be a little difficult to get  over there maybe invest in your public  infrastructure  maybe stop torturing black people and  shooting them for running away  replace your entire police force with a  new one that isn't terrorizing its  citizens and is an occupying army maybe  provide economic  opportunities to those in your  poverty stricken communities  and improve everyone everywhere all at  the same time